alors on va voir maintenant les sept
propositions on va vous dévoiler les
sept propositions que vous avez retenu
ce soir et avec lesquels la mine va
partir art auprès du gouvernement pour
aller les défendre et auprès du chef de
l'état la 7e mesure que vous avez retenu
ce soir est la septième propositions se
revoir les cycles horaires de la police
donc ça sera voilà ça fera partie la
gare donc des propositions qu'elle va
proposer et on espère que ça va avancer
là dessus en sixième position
le crédit d'impôt pour la compétitivité
et l'emploi réservé aux tpe et pme
si et ancien policier ça avait été
proposé par par notre avocat françois
qui étaient là tout à l'heure en
cinquième position
vous avez choisi la peine de prison pour
les fraudeurs fiscaux
françois également qu'elle applique à
notre avocat en quatrième position
vous avez choisi remise à plat et examen
de l'utilité de toutes les niches
fiscales à les sortir et ça c'est eric
naulleau est-ce que j'étais un drame
c'est le ministre naulleau j'ai
exactement
bravo monsieur nous loue voilà bah bravo
où le parlementaire ne l'eau continue à
m'appeler eric je restais pas allez on
va aller dans le top 3 maintenant ce
sont les sept vont être présentés 1
en troisième position le retour de l'
isf
et xavier avait proposé notre
restaurateur mais qui avait proposé le
retour de l' isf en deuxième position
augmenté de 2 à 4% il ya proposé ça tout
à l'heure et donc thierry on le voit
c'est en deuxième position ça fait
partie des priorités
en tout cas des français ce soir et
enfin en première position
la tva à taux zéro ce n'est qu'il avait
proposé au début alors olivier ya pas la
pénibilité
je sais tu es un peu déçu mais je pense
quand même qu'on va pouvoir
je pense que ça va être ça va faire
partie quand même des sujets qui vont
être abordés je suis sûr et certain
parce que je vous le redis il ya une
urgence voilà les agriculteurs et moi
surtout c'est la prime de pénibilité qui
est très importante parce que 350 euros
par mois c'est pas possible pour olivier
et et tous les tous les agriculteurs et
si on perd les agriculteurs je peux vous
dire c'est un drame pour la france et
olivier
je suis sûr que ça aussi ça va faire
partie des choses qui vont être
débattues et ça peut pas rester en
l'état
voilà donc les cette proposition avec
lesquels vous allez repartir
madame schiappa meriem reagan plus
exactement plus une qui est déjà
puisqu'elle est dans son d'ensemble
l'affairé wallace et c'est dans ces voix
là donc merci en tout cas vous allez
repartir avec ces sept on espère qu'on
va avoir des réponses concrètes
on espère qu'on va avoir des avancées en
tout cas on espère que ce soit en a fait
une émission qui va permettre de faire
avancer les choses qui arrivent dérivés
vous avez à choisir il ya un monsieur
qui voudrais juste dire un dernier truc
dans le public on y allait y aller si
karine pas d'accord commercialisé
d'abord je voudrais dire qu on a tout
entendu cette semaine tout entendu sur
notre émission tout entendu sur vous
tout entendu sur marlène schiappa tout
entendu sur les une capacité qu'on
aurait eu nous tout cela à débattre et à
proposer des choses il a précisé jeudi
que ce qui est totalement scandaleux au
fond parce que ça voudrait dire
effectivement que le débat réservée à
une caste de la société française qui se
considère comme une élite et nous qui
sommes le peuple on ne serait pas en
mesure de vos positions et je voudrais
vous remercier madame lise parce que
durant ce déferlement de charles muzy
parce qu'au fond c'est ça
il faut le dire clairement cheryl ann
darrow des jalousies garçon qui
réussissent d'alan à la société fait
aujourd'hui au lieu de dire bravo
il faut leur ressemble et on les jalouse
qu'est ce que vous voulez là où il faut
qu'on tienne un peu de culture caire
mais je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai
envie de vous remercier parce que vous
êtes venu et vous avez joué ce rôle des
coustous et beaucoup nous ont dit cette
semaine mais elle va faire sa propre à
gals mercer la pole à la soupe au
gouvernement en amont nous on n'est pas
là pour ça je veux dire vos collègues
députés et je crois vous êtes déjà venu
on souffre aucun de vos miches et donc
c'est pas facile parce que nous on est
passionné et on dit ce qu'on pense mais
personne au guide et ce soit madame
mistral a démontré qu'elle était
ministre à l'écouté de la population
elle prendre des propositions qui ne
sont pas les siennes elle valait relayée
j'espère avec beaucoup de conviction 2
parce que derrière ce débat madame la
ministre
et c'est vraiment eu envie de vous le
dire parce que ce soit vous êtes avec
nous et c'est important il faut qu'il y
ait des propositions il faut pas que ce
débat ce grand débat national au 15 mars
ne débouche sur des mesures est il faut
connais des grandes propositions bien
que notre pays à bas ou pas ils soient
plus chaud je suis d'accord avec les
dents juste ce grand débat national
je le dis verbal au cateau et je le dis
et je pense qu'elle a beaucoup qui
pensent comme moi il faut pas qu'ils
servent juste à gagner du temps tout à
fait voilà ça ça ça fait mal
mais voilà parce que nos bars donnera
pas